so we're told let f of x equal 2x
squared minus 18 over g of x where g of
x is a polynomial and then they tell us
which of the following is a possible
graph of y is equal to f of x and they
give us four choices here and like
always i encourage you to pause the
video and see if you could give a go at
it look at our f of x and then think
about which of these graphs actually
match up or could match up to that f of
x
all right now let's let's work through
this together and they don't give us a
lot of information they don't tell us
anything about the denominator of this
rational expression but they do tell us
this numerator and like we've seen
before it's useful to factor the
numerator and see at what x values do
interesting things happen in particular
at what x values does the numerator
equal 0 so if we factor the numerator up
here we could rewrite f of x
as being equal to let's see we could
factor out a 2 out of the numerator so
it's 2 times x squared minus 9 and
that's all going to be over g of x we
don't know what the denominator is we
just know that it's a polynomial
let's see here in the numerator x
squared minus 9 you might recognize that
as a difference of squares so we can
factor that further so we still have
that original 2 and it's going to be x
plus 3 times x
minus 3. we've seen that at multiple
times if that looks unfamiliar to you i
encourage you to watch the video on
differences of squares or factoring
polynomials x squared minus 9 is the
same thing as x squared minus 3 squared
so it's x plus 3 times x minus 3 and
then all of that is still going to be
over g of x
so the first thing that we might realize
is okay when does our numerator equal 0
well when when x is equal to negative 3
or when x is equal to positive 3. if x
is equal to negative 3 this expression
is going to be zero if x is equal to
positive three this expression is equal
to zero so you might just say well maybe
we have zeros at plus or minus three so
maybe at x is
maybe
maybe f of
negative 3 is equal to 0 and
f of positive 3 is equal to 0. those
values sure look like they make the
numerator equal to 0. and then we look
at our choices
and when we look at our choices
this choice a does seem to have a zero
at positive three but it doesn't have
one at negative three it has a vertical
asymptote at negative three so that
seems that seems a little bit confusing
this choice b does have a zero at
at positive three but it has nothing
going on here at or nothing interesting
going on at negative three it defines
negative three it doesn't even have a
vertical asymptote there so once again
this looks a little bit perplexing
choice c
choice c has a removable discontinuity
at positive three and then it has a
vertical asymptote at negative two so
once again this doesn't have anything
interesting going on at x is equal to
negative three so still a little
perplexing and this one has zeros at
positive six and negative six
so none of the choices have zeros at
both
x equals positive three and x equals
negative 3. so what's going on what we
need to realize is just because
something makes the numerator equal to 0
doesn't mean that it's definitely going
to be a 0 for that function and you
might say well how can that be well
think about situations in which those
values would also make the denominator
equal to zero so let me write out some
potential f of x's here so we just know
that g of x is a polynomial so f of x
could be we know the numerator two times
x plus three times x minus 3
over
well let's just say g of x is i'm just
going to make up something g of x is
equal to x plus 1.
well in this situation none of the
values that make the numerator equal 0
make the denominator equal 0. so this is
a situation where you would have two
zeros at x equals positive three and x
equals negative three so this would be
the two
two zeros
two
and so let's look at another situation
let's look at a situation where f of x
is equal to we know the numerator
x plus 3
times x minus 3 and let's say that we do
have
let's say that one of those x values
positive or negative 3 do make the
denominator equal to 0. so let's say
x plus 3 and then say times x plus 1.
well you see here now
since x plus 3 can is both in the
numerator and the denominator you could
divide x plus 3 divided by x plus 3 they
cancel out and here x equals negative 3
would be a removable discontinuity so
this would have this would have 0
0 at x equals three and a removable
removable discontinuity
at
x equals negative three
and so those values that make the
numerator equal to zero we now see it
could be a 0 or it could it could
represent a removable discontinuity and
here i just picked a removable
discontinuity to be at negative 3 it
could be or it could be the other way
around or it could be at both values if
this was x plus 3 times x minus 3 over x
plus 3 times x minus 3 then you would
have a removable discontinuity at both x
is positive 3 and negative 3. and then
you could go even further f of x could
look like this it could be 2 times x
plus 3
times x minus 3
over
x plus 3
squared and i'll just make up some other
another expression here x plus 1. so
what's going to happen here even if you
divide the numerator and denominator by
x plus 3 you're still going to have 1x
plus 3 left over in the denominator that
could cancel with one of the x plus 3s
but you're still going to have an x plus
3. and so in this case you would have a
vertical asymptote so in this case you
would have a 0
0 at x is equal to 3 and you would have
a vertical
asymptote
i'll just shorten it shorthand you'd
have a vertical i'll just write it out a
vertical asymptote
at x is equal to negative 3. so these
particular examples that i just showed
you showed you that any value that makes
the numerator equal zero aren't
necessarily zeros for the function they
could be zeros they could be removable
discontinuities or they could be
vertical asymptotes but they would all
occur at x is equal to positive or
negative three so with that lens now
let's look at the choices again
so choice a has a zero at x equals
positive three and it has a vertical
asymptote at x equals negative three so
that's actually very consistent with
this this circum this this situation
that i just described so choice a
actually is looking is looking pretty
good choice b has a zero at x equals
three but its vertical asymptote looks
like it's at x equals two and nothing
interesting is happening at x equals
negative three so we can rule that out
so you look at choice c you have a
removable discontinuity at x equals
positive three which is completely
possible we've seen that situation where
something that makes the numerator equal
zero could be removable discontinuity if
you have that same expression in the
denominator but then that vertical
asymptote isn't at x equals negative
three it's at x equals negative two so
that rules it out once again nothing
interesting happening at x equals
negative three and here you have two
zeros but they're not at x equals
positive or negative three they're at x
equals positive or negative six so we
can definitely rule that one out so we
should feel pretty good about
we should feel pretty good about choice
a